dernière journée du procès de carlos à
paris les plaidoiries des avocats de la
défense ont commencé ce matin le verdict
est attendu en fin de journée hier
l'avocat général de la cour d'assises à
recul a requis la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité contre ilitch ramirez sanchez
agnès vahramian bruno livertout aux
dernières paroles de l'avocat général
carlos applaudi applaudi et félicité
celui qui venait de demander la prison à
vie contre l'accusé
pour ses avocats ce n'est pas une
surprise rien d'inattendu et je crois
que si l'avocat général avait pu il
aurait requis la peine de mort votre
décision ne sera pas une décision de
guerre ou de vengeance mais simplement
l'application de la loi de la république
ces mots de l'avocat général ont semblé
soulager les familles touchées par le
comportement de carlos que je regrette
aujourd'hui c'est que carlos
effectivement comme le dit l'avocat
général
nous ne nous est pas dit voilà j'ai tué
votre père j'avais de bonnes raisons
pour le faire je le regrette je ne le
regrette pas
mais je les fais ça n'est pas un être
humain qui ressent que tout être humain
de respect du prochain
c'est une info j'ai les jambes carlos ne
voulait pas de ce procès prétendait se
défendre seul depuis ce matin sans
stratégie véritable ses avocats commis
d'office plaident pour lui la défense a
tenté de jeter le trouble sur la
présence rue toullier ce soir-là de
carlos
elle a aussi fait part de ses doutes sur
l'opération de la dst on vous cache
quelque chose
ont plaidé les avocats carlos eu écoute
mais un peu distrait et sans conviction
il attend la plaidoirie politique celle
qui fera de lui un combattant
révolutionnaire un héros mais carlos
sait déjà qu'il a perdu la partie